N
TONIGHT."
>> Tucker: SO IT MAY BE LOOKING
BACK, SAY, 10 YEARS FROM NOW,
ONE OF THE MOST SEQUENCAL
DECISIONS IN THE HISTORY OF BIG
TECH MAY HAVE BEEN TWITTER'S
DECISION TO BAN BABYLON BEE.
WHAT DID THE SITE DO WRONG?
TWITTER'S BAN WAS PUBLICIZED.
ELON MUSK SAW IT, AND WAS
OUTRAGED BY IT.
NOT BECAUSE HE'S A RIGHT WINGER,
BECAUSE HE BELIEVES IN THE FIRST
AMENDMENT.
ELON MUSK NOW OWNS TWITTER AND
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
TRYING TO DESTROY HIM.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
INVESTIGATING HIM.
THE PRESIDENT FROM THE PODIUM
NOT LONG AGO, SUGGESTED HE MIGHT
BE A THREAT TO NATIONAL
SECURITY.
SO ALL OF THIS BEGAN WITH THE
BANNING OF THE BABYLON BEE.
SETH DILLON IS THE CEO OF
BABYLON BEE AND JOINS US
TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN BANNED
ON TWITTER, BUT WHEN YOU GOT
BANNED, HE SEEMED TO SEE IT AS A
RED LINE BEING CROSSED.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT IS?
>> I THINK IT ALL GOES BACK TO
THE PRIMARY ISSUE OF FREE
SPEECH.
HE CALLS HIMSELF A FREE SPEECH
ABSOLUTIST.
ONE OF THE THINGS FREE SPEECH
PROTECTS IS JOKES.
WHEN YOU CAN'T EVEN LAUGH, POKE
FUN AT THESE IDEAS, ESPECIALLY
IDEAS THAT ARE REALLY CRAZY, WE
HAVE A SITUATION WHERE THIS
WORLD VIEW NEEDS TO BE PROPPED
UP.
THE LEFT'S INSANE IDEOLOGY NEEDS
TO BE PROPPEDDA BY SILENCING
PEOPLE ON THE OTHER SIDE,
ESPECIALLY BY PEOPLE WHO EXPOSE
THEIR FOOLISHNESS.
I THINK MUSK SAW THAT AS
PROBLEMATIC.
IT'S PART OF THE REASON WHY HE
DECIDED TO STEP IN AND TAKE SOME
ACTION.
>> Tucker: I'M GLAD HE DID.
HE'S THE RICHEST MAN IN THE
WORLD, FAMOUSLY, OR HE WAS WHEN
HE BOUGHT IT, IN ANY CASE, BUT
THERE'S SO MUCH INSTITUTIONAL
RESISTANCE TO ALLOWING AMERICANS
TO SPEAK FREELY.
DO YOU THINK HE WILL BE ABLE TO
RESTORE FREE SPEECH, LEGAL
SPEECH, MIGHT BE A BETTER
DEFINITION, TO TWITTER?
>> I HOPE SO.
I MEAN, FOR ALL OF OUR SAKES, I
HOPE SO.
THERE'S A LOT OF RESISTANCE.
HE'S FACING PRESSURING FROM
ADVERTISERS, FACING PRESSURE
FROM ACTIVIST GROUPS.
THEY HAVE THIS SYSTEM SET UP,
THIS POWER, EMPOWERED ACTIVISTS
BY GIVING THEM A SWORD AND
SHIELD, RIGHT?
THEY CAN STRIKE DOWN ANYTHING AS
MISINFORMATION OR HATE SPEECH
THAT THEY WANT.
ETHIC SMEAR YOU ALL THEY WANT.
THEY HAVE A SHIELD ON THE OTHER
SIDE.
THAT'S THEIR SWORD.
THEY HAVE A SHIELD ON THE OTHER
SIDE, WHERE YOU CAN'T CRITICIZE
THEM OR YOU GET BANNED.
MUSK HAS THREATENED TO TAKE AWAY
THAT SHIELD.
THEY WILL FIGHT TO THE DEATH TO
PREVENT HIM FROM DOING THAT.
HE'S GOT A TOUGH BATTLE AHEAD OF
HIM.
>> Tucker: I THINK YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
I DON'T THINK YOU'RE OVERSTATING
IT.
I THINK THE WORD "EXISTENTIAL,"
BUT THAT IS THIS FOR THEM.
DID YOU UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT
CENSORSHIP WAS FOR THE PEOPLE
CURRENTLY IN CHARGE TO KEEP
THEIR POWER?
I MEAN, THEY SEEM TO THINK IT'S
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING.
>> THEY DO.
I MEAN, THERE'S A REASON FOR
THAT.
YOU KNOW, MOCKERY AND -- AND --
AND CRITICISM, YOU KNOW, IT CAN
EXPOSE FOOLISHNESS, MAKE YOU
LOOK SILLY.
I THINK THAT'S THE BIG WEAK
POINT, ESPECIALLY WHEN IDEAS
THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DEFEND ARE
INDEFENSIBLE.
YOU KNOW, YOU DON'T WANT TO HAVE
ARGUMENTS ABOUT IT.
YOU WANT TO SHUT DOWN THE DEBATE
BEFORE THE DEBATE EVEN HAPPENS.
YOU KNOW, I DIDN'T EXPECT THAT
IT WOULD COME TO THE POINT IT'S
COME TO, THAT WE'D SEE THE
AMOUNT OF CONTENT MODERATION
WE'RE SEEING, THAT BASICALLY
SILENCES ONE SIDE OF THE
DISCUSSION AND TAKES OUT PEOPLE
TRYING TO USE HUMOR EFFECTIVELY
IN A CONVERSATION.
YOU KNOW, HERE WE ARE, WE'RE IN
THIS PLACE.
I DON'T KNOW.
I'M EXCITED, HOPEFUL, THAT MUSK
WILL FIGHT BACK AND DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THIS.
HE'S FACING CHALLENGES RIGHT OUT
OF THE GATE.
>> Tucker: YEAH, HE CERTAI